throughout history there have been many
different names for public drinking
spaces saloons taverns and pubs to name
a few the area in which the bartender
mixes and serves drinks is known as the
bar today this is the standard
nomenclature for the place that will
most definitely have some pontificating
quad and a vest explaining to you the
difference between single and double
malt whiskey thanks for the history
lesson pal I use Wikipedia too but I
just ordered a double whiskey handed you
my credit card and said leave it open
clearly I have no interest in learning
anything tonight that's the trouble
though today everyone's an expert you're
constantly bombarded with information
you didn't ask for about things you
could care less about what type of beer
do I want how about one I think heard of
you shouldn't have to hand me literature
that explains what it is I'm about to
order I just want a logger okay it's the
most common type of beer in the world
what's that I don't sell lagers of
course you do
why would you you only have a hundred
and twenty-six different kinds of beer
just give me the one with oatmeal that
has a reserve in its name the funny dude
with mustache on the label and God
forbid you order one of the signature
cocktails because that's gonna require
six months to make it would take less
time for you to grapple the idea of
running a marathon ultimately decide to
join a running club that trains four
times a week meet new people that you
eventually call friends and break
boundaries you didn't know where
possible as you place in the top 10% out
of the New York Marathon you could do
all of that
and go back there he's still making the
drink he's testing it with his little
straws yeah all right and when you
eventually do get your drink that comes
standard with a giant ball of ice that
could easily doubles an assault weapon
it cost more than a month subscription
to Netflix and Hulu it's only okay also
why the hell is there a dress code I'm
gonna design a shirt and shorts that
cost more than your car but this chick
who's barely wearing anything don't even
wrong I'm not complaining she's cool
seems like a pretty flawed business
model if you ask me who you thinks gonna
move more inventory guys the substance
abuse problem or the lightweight who's
drunk after half a sip I didn't have any
dinner you know what I'm never coming in
here again this used to be my favorite
bar then it turned into a goddamn
speakeasy and you do realize speakeasy
is an antiquated term don't you I forgot
who I'm dealing with of course you knew
that you know everything actually sir
speakeasy comes from the Prohibition era
when alcohol was banned probably safe to
say if there's a nanny on sign a
television or an obscene amount of
banners in sight like wanna drown your
sorrows
because if you drink in there you might
end up drowning yourself in the bathroom
it's 100% organic absinthe
thanks again for watching be sure to
follow on social and subscribe and check
out other episodes gaining is a verb a
relationship is a noun a verb is an
action while a noun is a thing